and it is
making his return to a big league
mountain here with the rangers this will
be his eighth start of the season but as
you mentioned dave in the open it's been
nearly four months that we have seen him
pitch overall number 6.59 era he really
ran into some trouble over his last
couple of starts and that's when that
injury started to present a problem for
kohei
swinging a miss city gets his first
strike out of the afternoon one away
goes change up right on right just in
off the plate and it's actually a split
didn't have a lot of depth it looked
like a change that actually was the
split finger and well located for the
first strike out of the afternoon well
they play rogers pretty much straight up
on the infield the 2-1 pitch that's
flared out to right and adolesce garcia
is right there
they're two gone
and here comes the one two
and he got him swinging it was a change
up but a couple of strikeouts in a
perfect first for kohei arijaro welcome
back got a home run hitting right handed
for kyle 18th start this year five and
six record as i mentioned in the month
of august four and oh the walk total is
really decreased
[Applause]
and a good start ground ball to the
right side brendan rodgers gets some uh
practice
connor felefa
16 to 22 and a chase on a breaking ball
that was out of the zone yeah it was a
curveball that didn't really do a whole
lot just took the mile an hour off on
the subaru super bowl it just ended up
being one of those mistakes that turned
out okay turned out well right you don't
say that very often we always you're
like oh that was a mistake and it got
hit hard well that was a mistake that he
got the strikeout on
this ball is loud glove by story what a
catch by trevor taking away a knock from
dj peters well peters robbed the story
yesterday story said i remember that
i have a long memory
and that misses so the second walk
of the game for kyle freeland that'll
bring up nick solac what's going on here
i don't know is it his finger because he
really hasn't had command of of anything
today and you just hope that blister
issue didn't pop back up again we
haven't talked about it i know it starts
what i don't like about this is
you know they're not even looking at
anything it's almost as if there
may have been something that they
chatted about earlier were aware of
earlier and they're just
revisiting that discussion
kyle's coming out well the rockies
weren't expecting to change pitchers in
the second but that's what has unfolded
as kyle freeland has left the game and
right-hander justin lawrence is on
road teams
this one on the ground into left field
that's a base hit low stops at second on
the single by nick solace
as culberson takes a walk and the bases
are loaded and here is joelle pozo now
with the bases loaded nobody out
and two and pozo hits it on the ground
and into left field that's a base hit
low is in they wave solac the throw
comes through
and they got him what a peg from connor
joe it was a perfect one hop strike and
anything short of perfect solak probably
scores
that one way off the plate ball four
they're loaded again but he's going to
take the baseball from lawrence bases
loaded one out a run in for texas ben
boat coming on
coyote tavares come to the plate
pitch
and that ball head out into left field
connor joe angling back it's over his
head and then bounces away from him
along the wall one run is in pozo right
behind he'll score
tavares with a two run double and the
rangers lead three nothing the better
news is that leone seems to have figured
it out at the plate right now he gets a
3-2 fastball that's down and he goes
down and gets it and put a charge into
it connor joe made an effort but he
wasn't anywhere near it with connor
falefa coming to the plate
[Applause]
the 1-2
and that one out to the alley in right
field that gets down it'll play two more
counter falloffa with a two-run single
and he makes it five-nothing rangers
two-two and a swing and a miss finally
gets the rockies off the field
he's to be allowed to face brendan
rodgers now
10 up 10 down for the rangers
right-hander
3-2
and this ball's hit pretty well to
center field
and over the wall running into the wall
was tavares and brendan rodgers with the
rocky's first hit it's a home run so
it's 5-1 the 11th of the year for rogers
nine of which have come out on the road
and how many have been to dead center
field too i mean it just seems he has
that power stroke to that area on the
field either way a really good outing
for kohei arihara first time he's
pitching to big leagues since early may
he's going to get a nice round of
applause from the folks here this
afternoon 11th game of the season for
wes benjamin 15 strikeouts for him this
year
and the 3-2 pitch is low ball four so
benjamin walks the first man he sees
trevor story to hit one ball one strike
on story and this ball aligned in the
center field
charlie's going to go first to third and
the rockies have a little something
going here two down two on and here's
ryan mcmahon
within the concept of the team this has
a chance to drop and it will so blackman
will score story's got to dive back into
second he is safe there and it's five to
two on an rbi single by mcmahon
one on one out and this ball lined down
the left field line see if it gets all
the way to the corner it'll get to the
track before it's cut off there by
peters
and it'll be a double stopping at third
is hilliard
and the rockies are in business again
with one out in the fifth after putting
two on the board in the fourth
and that gets through hilliard's gonna
score
going to third
is connor joe it's five to three here
come the rockies with a little
assistance from demarcus evans
charlie's coming up right now
and this ball is pulled to second
charlie's got to get up the line
and he did and the run scores he may be
35 but we've seen him run like he's 25
on a number of occasions this year
chopper second base solac with the tag
the throw to first double play
nicely done by nick solak and the inning
is over well that is how you eliminate a
walk and make up for it get the weak
ground ball count on your defense
excellent work here by solace to tag the
spin and the throw on the money to get
out to speedy topia rangers grand slam
came on sunday and it was adolesce
garcia fifth inning of that game that'll
be garcia again with a chance here with
the bases loaded here we go 2-2
got him with a slider so bard works out
of it and the emphatic uh hand slapped
to his glove he keeps it a one-run game
tying run down at second and on to the
next guy and that next guy is brendan
rodgers
this ball hammered left center field
this could tie it diaz scores easily
hanson's getting a green light he'll
score standing up and the rockies take a
6-5 lead brendan rodgers coming through
a three-rbi afternoon for rogers and the
rockies take the lead they were down 5-0
early and here comes trevor story that's
just a local kid yeah just open it up
too
1-0 hard on the ground to third trevor
that's a low throw or run scores
blackman's going to move up story's
going to move up charlie around third
he's coming home and he is safe there's
that was a low throw
and all the way to third goes story
and the rangers
right now their fans are saying we look
like a 47-85 team
yang
and on one pitch oh my goodness this
could be another error oh
the rockies get a ninth run and
unfortunately for nathaniel lowe he'd
like to uh crawl under a rock and hide
that should be two errors on that play
and then the throw it will be yep
this should be two there's one there's
two
ball game over rockies come back and win
it nine to five the five run deficit
is the largest deficit the rockies have
overcome to win a ball game this year
they go four and five on the road trip
and they'll have a happy return to
denver trevor story it was good
homecoming for him he swung the bat
exceptionally well a lot to do on the
steel post game show shasine gets the
win barlow takes the loss